bom dia
mas o daniel ribas surfista plástica e
gostava de usar por suicidar o grupo dos
cocos loucos e tiveram queda em um ano
amanhã 11 quer que eu achei
extraordinária os cenotes ele já tomou e
hoje vai encarar falaram querendo
autocom site o do self mais design
a saída é quando eu saía por escolher a
minha vida profissional tem que fazer
uma escolha profunda entra
será que o que eu queria ser ou talento
do mundo é partilhado que é um carinho
que vocês todos aqui estão a fazer como
alunos do instituto superior técnico
então dentro do dew partilhado o qq onde
começa então o meu auto conceito é o
mesmo e científico e eu vou explicar por
que por que por questões genéticas meio
ambiente educação eu china xi e áfrica
sou filha de uma senhora humanista em um
paciente estaria do instituto superior
técnico tem mais quatro anos na família
eu quero dizer um carinho na minha
dignidade de ser livre mas fiz essa
escolha hoje eu sou uma mãe humanista
científica a saída foi muito
influenciada pela minha mãe e pelo meu
pai e também na altura da minha vida já
não seria fazer porque eram duas
correntes muito forte dentro de mim e eu
não tinha não sabia como conduzi las até
que também altura se de tornar um
artista como é que o torna artista
porque eu não conseguir um bom
partilhado eu falava em tempo eu não
conseguia entrar dentro do sistema e
fazer as coisas como mandavam porque eu
era criativa por circunstâncias de vida
acabou por largar tudo que fazia tem
muitos empregos e um dia deus nós temos
de começar a pintar e durou até hoje
o mecanismo foi o princípio foi a
primeira grande influência da minha vida
porque eu passei 20 anos em angola
portanto a minha formação
isso é das em áfrica e com razão porque
a áfrica é sobre as pessoas até aos
poucos museus partilhados é tudo muito
espontâneo a uma civilização que
procurou sem deus partilhados e portanto
eu fui livro na forma como che e como
assim mais musculoso inicialmente um sai
por pintar paisagens que me emocionavam
que tenham a ver com exposições
africanos as queimadas um período muito
emocional
até que terminaram todas uma grande
mudança na minha vida eu descubro o a
bola ficou com um copo a vocês todos
devem estar já foram organizados e
consegue pintar as paisagens do universo
do design porque esta técnica resinas
epóxi que era muito difícil por pintar o
universo se não se consegue nada não são
de dimensão que é homem o infinito para
as cartas do tarot não é
é muito complicado tem uma série de
planetas para disse moll dez anos as
resinas epóxi que a soma entre as 130 do
tholl eu cerca de dez minutos nesta
tecla enter de fazer em dez minutos
o vôo muito tempo até porque os olhos da
crise e tudo isso
mistura-se maneiras de frente ativa
sorte do conselho por sua tribo lê que é
um dos grandes mentores já estão
ensinado foi também meu nome é o mentor
científico eu vi o aval por acaso e
fiquei completamente apaixonada e
pedirei com soul é minha formação
científica eo conceito algumas conversas
com pessoas sem goleiro conseguiu abrir
o universo da ciência foi pó para
monique boal pesa para a nasa conseguiu
falar com cientistas e isso mudou acabou
por roubar o meu percurso ao sul dirija
aos 30 anos o que que fui importante
para mim
da criação do estatuto o conceito é o
humanismo e científico
primeiro foi descoberto um microscópio e
depois do dos coppio porque o
microscópio um microscópio explicou
algumas coisas como por exemplo o final
da guerra
eu olho para o meu corpo e perceber que
tem um sistema monetário no sistema
imunitário é um exército assassino do
chelsea que marcou outras
e portanto eu consigo perceber pois
nunes na vida humana existem exatamente
o mesmo paralelo eu como artista
pensadora querem filosofam foi
encontrado na ciência algumas respostas
das questões
a amarok é no fundo a visão do infinito
do que é infinitamente grande que hoje
através de física quântica científica do
universo diferente também têm moldado
pedindo a minha obra porque eu penso
humano duas formas diferentes
a massa é o corpo eo que é um corpo e
por tudo aquilo que acontece de forma
enfim no nosso corpo
nós estamos a olhar por ser humano
estamos a olhar só uma maneira não
estamos a olhar de outra e assim
acertamos a permitir descobrimos um
milhão possibilidade
aquilo que é um deus partilhado depois
mais à frente com o santo mais
cientistas - cientistas
acabei por descobrir este conceito
também confeccionou saiu quando vir o
aborto de três horas o universo e de
repente virou uma terra e tecnológico
computando os postulados cidades
organizadas com o senhor enquanto você
em computadores mais uma vez mudei a
minha visão do eu comecei a perceber que
nós somos os computadores de carbono são
o computador não é de energia biológica
depois temos os computadores de sílica
acaba por primeira ao desmontar milhares
de telemóveis do maquiné acho que há um
paralelo entre o tempo de recesso
oficial da inteligência humana como é
que entra a ciclagem isso também
conhecida por ser uma artista reciclagem
é proibido justamente as duas coisas pra
mim são uma não há diferenciação
eles querem final entre a máquina o
homem pra mim é máquina é só e
estenderam prolongadas que as
capacidades humanas nós temos lugar
porque andamos temos 95 anos temos
internet as capacidades do pat cash e
por aí fora tanto eu fiz um casamento
uma visão científica é justamente isto é
o casamento entre duas realidades nos
parecem distantes mas pra mim não são
eu vou fábricas buscar tudo o que é lixo
e acabo por compor uma idéia humanos com
base em material presenteia que esta
obra chama maior porte estão o
computador mas há ali uma mãe programar
o computador então a peça vídeo é uma
média não precisei não faças isso vai
ver letterman vestir um casaco não
mintas que o que nós fizemos também que
os computadores não têm e são assinados
quando eu vi o avô papaterra eu fiquei
surpreendida perceber como é que como é
um desejo partilhado é exatamente o
aluno contou esta visão que eu tive e
percebeu consegue fazer estas obras
continua trial e não pareceu muito o
isto é uma cesta é uma fotografia com
cuidado pelo professor cosme do abba o
futuro é filho direto do espaço e
esteves é vista do meu quarto foi como
eu imaginei que daqui uns anos a gente
deveria o da terra os deveriam viver no
planeta
olha após passar depois de estudar o que
nem todos estão com saúde
depois eu acabei por perder um pedido da
ciência e consciência todos com sete
tiros em uma delas foi a bola ea ouvir
um desafio da fundação das
telecomunicações podem dar uma visão uma
tendência evolutiva das conexões de um
evento em goiânia
xhafa enviar orgânico é um olho que vê
noite vê à distância e memoriza em
formação que nós deixamos de ter
privacidade nós passamos a ser uma
refletiva modelo quadrado cada um nós
consegue em
um tanque com outros para transmitir que
está a passar no céu a x muito
interessante porque vamos por ser um
cérebro e tive não andarmos
individualmente a fazer as coisas nós
tínhamos um organismo unidos
star wars bione isso foi
foi uma exposição que eu fiz o odone é
que está o homem biônico também fez uma
exposição sobre o homem biônico é um
homem esqueçam tudo obra já bastante
antigas
este é um homem já tem toda a eletrônica
dentro do corpo tanto exagero ou sérvios
já certo que maquinaria se torna super
humano estão transman ficarem pois o som
da banda também vivendo a bola e
consegue olhar o berço da humanidade e
que você perceber que está em roma este
movimento científica que estavam lá
outras áreas muitas zonas do planeta em
áfrica nomeadamente mas ainda não vi a
instrução corporal houve apenas uns
externo com ainda sócios de forma
externa kyoto é que o que influência
social tem um saiba finalmente chegou e
é também por ir muito mais longe na
minha investigação é que vai poder fazer
esta exposição agora sobre o trabalho do
mano fala sobre a questão do fim do
mecanismo e isto é uma questão muito
pertinente nesta altura porque nós
estamos numa função social é muito
importante hoje em dia já estou em
londres e vou atravessar a estrada então
senhor ou adaptações como as pernas
biônicas são coordenadas pelo cego eu já
estou numa segunda dimensão sem me faz
muita confusão mas a verdade é que tudo
é que o que nós nos consideramos que são
os trechos eletrônicos com a nossa volta
que já são milhões para resolver tudo
com a querida que há dez anos não lembro
do nosso corpo
tanto esta corrente do humanismo
científico o evento essas questões que é
filosóficas para saber se nós estamos
preparados e queremos como é que a gente
defender como mais clientes continuarão
a ser humano assunto
ser uma espécie de superar mas com
capacidade de transferência tais e vamos
perdendo muita parte das nossas
inseminadas opções como o efi é essa
questão eu vá ter com este ato
autoconceito sobre o humanismo
científico muito obrigado
[Aplausos]